SERVED TIME OR WAS CHARGE FOR
THAT.
HIS LAWYER SAYS THEY PLAN TO
HIGHLIGHT THE DIFFERENCES
BETWEEN CLINTON'S TREATMENT AND
HIS.
AFTER MORE THAN A YEAR OF WASTED
TIME ON THE FANTASY OF RUSSIAN
COLLUSION IN THE 2016 ELECTION
THERE IS STILL NO EVIDENCE THAT
ANY OF IT ACTUALLY HAPPENED.
THAT DOESN'T MEAN THAT LIVES
HAVEN'T BEEN DESTROYED.
MANY HAVE BEEN, BEGINNING WITH
GEORGE PAPADOPOULOS WHO AT THE
TIME WAS A 28-YEAR-OLD UNPAID
ADVISOR TO THE CAMPAIGN.
HE LATER FLED TO A CHARGE OF
MAKING FALSE STATEMENTS TO
FEDERAL INVESTIGATORS LOOKING
INTO RUSSIA.
HE HAS NOT YET BEEN SENTENCED.
HIS WIFE JOINS US TONIGHT.
FOR COMING ON.
>> THANK YOU FOR HOSTING ME.
>> Tucker: SO YOU MARRIED HER
HUSBAND AFTER THIS INVESTIGATION
HUSBAND AFTER THIS INVESTIGATIO
INVESTIGATION, WHEN HE HAD
BECOME FAMOUS FOR HIS REPORTED
COLLUSION WITH RUSSIA.
YOU ARE CONFIDENT HE DID NOT
COLLUDE IN ANY WAY WITH THE
RUSSIAN GOVERNMENT.
>> I KNOW HE DID NOT AND
ACTUALLY ONE OF THE REASONS WHY
I'M HERE TONIGHT, THANK YOU FOR
HOSTING ME, TO SET THE RECORD
STRAIGHT ABOUT GEORGE.
IN PARTICULAR, IN RESPONSE TO
JIM COMEY'S STATEMENT WHICH SAYS
THAT GEORGE TRIED ACTIVELY TO
OBTAIN EMAILS, THIS STATEMENT IS
COMPLETELY FALSE.
HE NEVER HAD ANY DIRECTION WITH
THE RUSSIANS.
HE HAS NEVER BEEN TO RUSSIA
EITHER.
YET APPARENTLY THE REASON FOR
THIS RUSSIA INVESTIGATION.
THIS IS QUITE PARADOXICAL FOR
ME.
>> Tucker: MY UNDERSTANDING IS
THAT ALL OF THIS BEGINS IN MARCH
OF 2016 WHEN HE WAS APPROACHED
IN LONDON BY A MALTESE PROFESSOR
WHO HAS SINCE DISAPPEARED WITH
THE OFFER OF INFORMATION
FROM THE RUSSIANS.
WHAT HAS HAPPENED TO THAT
PROFESSOR, DO YOU KNOW?
>> I KNOW THIS PROFESSOR BECAUSE
I USED TO WORK WITH HIM.
THE FACT THAT HE DISAPPEARED IS
VERY SUSPICIOUS.
THAT'S WHAT I KNOW ABOUT THIS
MEETING BETWEEN GEORGE AND THE
PROFESSOR, TALKING CASUALLY
ABOUT INFORMATION THAT WAS ARTIE
IN THE PUBLIC DOMAIN AT THE TIME
THEY MET.
WE HAVE TO UNDERSTAND HE WAS
TALKING ABOUT, NOT ABOUT THE DNC
EMAILS.
IT'S A COMPLETELY DIFFERENT
TOPIC.
IT WAS A VERY CASUAL
CONVERSATION THAT JOSH
VOLUNTARILY REPORTED TO THE FBI.
IT BECAME APPARENTLY THE REASON
WHY PEOPLE -- THE THINGS CALLED
COLLUSION BUT ACTUALLY NEVER
COLLUDED.
HIS JOB, PARTICULARLY IN ISRAEL.
>> Tucker: HE WORKED AT THE
HUDSON SUIT HERE AND WAS A BIG
PROPONENT OF ISRAEL.
THIS PROFESSOR, WHO DO YOU THINK
HE WAS WORKING FOR?
WHAT WAS THAT ABOUT AND WHERE DO
YOU THINK HE HAS GONE?
WHAT WAS HIS AGENDA?
>> I HONESTLY HAVE NO IDEA.
MY PERSONAL OPINION, WHICH I
THAT IS A VERY SHADY CHARACTER.
RECENTLY I HEARD HE DOESN'T WANT
TO APPEAR PUBLICLY BECAUSE OF
THE SITUATION HE'S INVOLVED IN
TO GEORGE.
MY UNDERSTANDING IS THAT WAS
GOSSIPING ABOUT THE EMAILS.
AGAIN, I REMEMBER THIS
INFORMATION WAS ALREADY HIGHLY
SPECULATED BY ALL MEDIA ALL OVER
THE WORLD AT THE TIME.
THERE WAS NOTHING SECRET ABOUT
THAT.
AND ACTUALLY FRUSTRATING TO SEE
MY HUSBAND IN THE CENTER OF THIS
INVESTIGATION FOR TALKING IN A
BAR.
EVEN THE MEETING IN LONDON,
WHICH APPARENTLY ORIGINATED THE
RUSSIAN INVESTIGATION IS
CONTESTED.
HE NEVER CONFIRMED THAT GEORGE
EXPLICITLY TALKED ABOUT THE
EMAILS.
>> Tucker: IT DOESN'T MAKE A
LOT OF SENSE.
WHERE IS HER HUSBAND NOW?
IS UNDER A GAG ORDER IS MY
UNDERSTANDING AWAITING
SENTENCING, IS THAT RIGHT?
>> HE IS AWAITING SENTENCING AND
THAT'S WHY I THINK IT'S VERY
IMPORTANT TO SET THE RECORD
STRAIGHT RIGHT NOW.
BECAUSE THERE ARE A LOT OF
MISUNDERSTANDINGS ABOUT THE
SITUATION, ABOUT HIS ROLE.
I USED TO SAY THAT HIS ROLE IS
VERY IMPORTANT.
I USED TO COMPARE HIM -- I NEVER
MEANT TO MAKE THIS COMPARISON IN
THE SENSE THAT WOULD LEAD TO THE
PRESIDENCY IMPEACHMENT.
I THINK HE'S BEEN APPROACHED BY
MANY DIFFERENT CHARACTERS, LET'S
SAY SPIES, HE HAS BEEN THE
VICTIM.
I'M SURE HE WILL BE HAPPY TO
SHARE THIS INFORMATION WHEN THE
TIME IS RIGHT.
>> Tucker: DO YOU THINK YOUR
IS GOING TO PRISON?
>> I KNOW HOW MUCH IT WAS
COMMITTED TO THE TRUMP CAMPAIGN.
I KNOW HE DID AN EXCELLENT JOB.
BECAUSE OF THIS INCIDENT,
FREEDOM IS CHALLENGED.
I TRUST AND HOPE AND ASK